comment ne pas fêter Noël sans le
traditionnel sapin habillé de ses boules
scintillantes et autres guirlandes
électriques dans cette entreprise de
Manil et amau les arbres les plus
originaux pourraient investir votre
salon cela va du sapin en bois au plus
surprenant le sapin spirale peut-être le
conifère du futur sans oublier le modèle
en plastique recyclé fabriqué par une
entreprise de trappe son design permet
de faire passer les traditionnelles
guirlandes à travers ses trous le
principe de des sapins en plastique
recyclé c'est fait par des matières à 80
% recyclé et on a fait un design
spécifique coupé au laser pour
pouvoir les utiliser dans les les
entreprises cet aspect développement
durable l'entreprise cinquantinoise y
est très attachée verdco récupère l'eau
de pluie pour arroser les plantes de la
serre un espace alimenté par des
panneaux photovoltaïques et chauffé
entièrement par une chaudière à bois
contrairement à ce qu'on P on peut
penser c'est une une politique qui est
gagnante je cité par ex
s devine un pourreise c'est un gain
puison revend le compost queon produit
tous les ans pour vous offrir ces sapins
nouvelle génération il vous faudra
débourser tout de même entre 240 et 450
€